what do you think I mean obviously it's
disheartening but like you know is your
work been affected although it's been
going on like certain people you can't
work with now or actors or actresses or
not every time you can't somebody you
have to panic like like Ridley Scott
just kind of took Kevin Spacey out of
the movie right yeah I mean I'm lucky
because I work with so many women so
there's none you know so far they've
been clean but uh I don't know you you
you don't really I don't you can't
really factor that in Alan I look
whenever I work with anybody I always do
kind of a check around the town to find
out if they're an [ __ ] and so
generally that'll fall into the same
category so I've been really lucky
though see all you do check around
though you you'll say someone else has
worked with this person Heiser hey
life's too short to be stuck for months
what do you do if you're stuck with
somebody on the set who you don't like
it's usually it's the directors like
you'll ask the actors what do you do if
there's a director who's a screamer what
do you have you I'm sure you're done
with actors who just don't want to take
direction yeah I've had a couple it's
been worse
it was worse in television because
you're sort of a hired hand who comes in
and there's the cast who've been there
and a lot of them sometimes just have
this thing of like all right [ __ ] you
you're this guy you know who's this is
our job every day and you're coming in
right it's a guest but I've been pretty
lucky I only had a couple of bad
experiences how do you handle it you
just kind of put your head down and get
through it because what it is is a lot
of times you're trying to get them to do
something they don't want to do that the
producers want you to get them to do and
so it's your job to make it happen no
matter what and you know everyone's well
I just like look they want you to do
this I know what to tell you and some
think they'll usually come around I mean
what happens once the camera rolls
people usually pull it together because
nobody wants a bad perform so you'll
tell them like after a while like look
this is not me they asked me to tell you
to do this and it's up to you if you
don't do it that that's my last resort
if I if I'm trying to get them to do
something that I don't believe in
because that's a lot of times like the
producers like you got to come to say
there's something like that's a really
dumb joke or that's not right or that's
not their voice and that's what I'll
just resort you look at you worked with
so many women no have you heard like at
least rumblings or these stories that
Lake I think a lot of people are kind of
shocked when the Weinstein thing starts
and then it snowballs into know it's
happening across no I mean there's
definitely there's definitely kind of a
group of names you would hear over and
over again who
bad reputations the we thing about
Harvey was because I was worked with him
I had a project with him that I ended up
not doing because I just felt like life
was too short had enough people tell me
it was more than Marlon Wayans was like
don't do it it's not worth it
well we're dealing with him yeah do a
movie with him he'd had bad experiences
with him but I had only heard what a
jerk he was and how hard he was to work
with I had somehow not heard the you
know the sexual store oh thank god they
won't wear one of your suits when that
homeboy that that's the biggest scary
thing now with the sad the perpetrator
can be glad